one of the biggest questions many have
had about Hogwarts Legacy is just how
the combat will work after all in the
state of Play trailer we saw some pretty
impressive Combos and fluid transitions
between different spells plus there's a
recent clip showing off the incendio
spell that revealed some spells will
have multiple uses and aren't just for
combat spell casting in combat is one
aspect that many of the previous Harry
Potter video games have always struggled
with take for example the console
version of Prisoner of Azkaban where
there were actually quite a few puzzles
and areas designed around the player
needing to use different spells to
progress the only problem is you were
limited to just two spell slots which
made switching back and forth rather
tedious in the PC game spells were
entirely contextual and based only on
your surrounding environment so you
couldn't even choose which spell you
were casting it was only based on the
objects you were aiming at the console
versions of Harry Potter and the Goblet
of Fire actually took the same approach
as well then Order of the Phoenix and
Half Blood Prince introduce a system
where you would actually use the right
stick or actual hand movements in the
case of the Nintendo Wii to cast certain
spells and we really don't even need to
talk about what happened with Deathly
Hallows so one of my personal hopes for
a really well made made Wizarding World
game has always been if they could nail
the spell casting in a way that's
intuitive not repetitive and most
importantly fun well after two gameplay
showcases we have a much better idea of
how spell casting is going to work in
the game and honestly I'm pretty
encouraged by what they've shown so far
when it comes to spell casting in
Hogwarts Legacy everything starts with
the right trigger so if you tap R2 that
throws out a basic shot but that R2 is
also your gateway to all of the the uh
spells that you might slot so if you
hold R2 instead you can see how the
diamond expands and if we let go you see
how it contracts yeah and so if you hold
it again it expands by holding it down
button prompts appear on the four spells
slotted in the bottom right corner this
reveals the face buttons and pressing
one of those four buttons while still
holding R2 will activate the
corresponding slotted spell and these
can be arranged any way you want now
just a bit further down we see a d-pad
icon with one section that's shaded
slightly different from the others this
section represents the active set of
spells that we see above so while
holding R2 if we instead hit one of the
other three Direct on the d-pad a new
set of spells will appear we haven't
seen what the customization screen will
look like just yet but the basic idea
here is that we'll have four sets of
four spells to correspond with each
button on the d-pad which means we'll
have easy access to at least 16 of the
slottable Spells at any given time so
all those combos and quickly switching
back and forth between all the different
spells that we've seen in the trailer
that's how they do it as for how many
spells are present game director Alan 2
has revealed there are more than 20
slotable spells we also got a blurred
look at what could potentially be the
full list of spells during the second
gameplay showcase and of course fans
have already slotted many of the Spells
we know about into a spot with a list of
the unknowns as well you'll also note
the color coding system Avalanche has in
place to separate out different types of
spells we have damage spells which are
red and so far we know about confringo
incendio defendo and possibly
Expelliarmus that is if you believe this
icon here is Expelliarmus which leaves
one unknown damage spell now as for the
purple spells you can think of these as
four spells and here we have Akio which
is noted with the hand pulling back and
the arrow we have descendo which is the
hand pointing down and the depulso with
the hand pushing forward and again that
leaves one spell we don't know about in
this category then we move on to Yellow
which are control spells here we have
the hand in the upright position and
this is the icon for a Resto momentum
then we have the feather here which is
actually levioso not Wingardium Leviosa
fun facts Leviosa is purely a levitation
spell whereas when guardian Leviosa
actually allows you to move the object
instead of course it's still possible
that that spell is in the game as well
and since we actually have two slots
here in the yellow that are open very
possible it could fit into one of those
two slots we have a dark green color
coding here and we actually know about
all three of these spells because this
is where the unforgivable spells are
slotted Avada Kedavra crucio and imperio
then we have a set of light green spells
and it seems that all of these are
actually associated with different
actions you're going to be taking in the
room of requirement we have one here
with a cup one with two arrows and then
one that looks like some sort of cloud
or pellet possibly evanesco maybe to
remove an object speaking of Wingardium
Leviosa maybe that's the arrow spell you
can kind of only move objects around I
don't know the icon doesn't really fit
with my guardian Leviosa and then we
have the cup which I've seen some
speculation could be a way to feed or
give water to the animals or maybe it's
a Conjuring type of Icon instead as in
transforming the cup into something else
we actually got our best look at these
in the second gameplay showcase during
the final section where they really go
into detail on the room of requirement
and everything we'll be able to do there
then we have the light blue section of
spells which we do not have a name for
these I'm going to call them utility
spells because the only one we know
about here is lumos so not really a
combat spell we've actually seen lumos
used in the previous games to do some
puzzle solving and to reveal certain
locations of course in the books we know
this is basically like a flashlight for
wizards very handy to always have on you
so there are three of those spells that
we don't know about and then we have
three more that are kind of a darker
blue color and it appears that these
three are also all related to Fantastic
Beasts one for cleaning and taming we
see the little brush here this one is
most likely feeding and then we have a
bag here which could be used for
capturing the creatures or rescuing the
creatures depending on what type of
wizard you want to be I guess now if you
notice there are a couple of confirmed
spells that I did not mention in the
slottable category that's because
there's an additional set of spells that
they're referring to as essential spells
these are spells that are going to be
important for you to have quick access
to be able to use these at any given
time and these are actually mapped to
other buttons on the controller so these
are not triggered by R2 for example we
have left on the d-pad which is going to
be revello R1 for a pugno I mean the
ancient magic throw apparently looks
like that one has been changed maybe due
to a lore reason and then another one we
know about is protego which is The
Shield charm this is going to be used by
pressing triangle on PlayStation
controllers which means why for Xbox
controllers now another spell that's
been confirmed is stupefy and what's
interesting about how this one is cast
is it's really being used as sort of a
counter attack at least in terms of the
way they described it in the second
gameplay showcase they said when you
block with bertego if you hold down
triangle you'll actually fire back
Stupify as a counter spell so it remains
to be seen if we'll be able to set
Stupify as its own own separate spell
we've also seen petrificus totalus being
used specifically in the stealth section
here and so it actually appears on the
square button and it only appears here
in this contextual situation so when
you're sneaking around you sneak up
behind this guy and then you can pers
Square for petrificus totalis one of the
game's Biggest Mysteries continues to be
the ancient magic and our character's
connection to it you can even use the
mysterious powerful magic your
professors do not understand to
obliterate your strongest foes as you
chain combo attacks against enemies and
collect the blue magical Aura Left
Behind after some fights you'll power up
your ancient magic meter once it reaches
the halfway point you'll be able to
trigger an incredibly powerful attack
using L1 and R1 in the Showcase we see
this manifest itself in three different
attacks one that has this sort of
exploding effect and then another one
that's just completely makes the enemy
disappears this sort of black smokey
effect and then one that turns the enemy
into a chicken now as we have seen a few
things already changed since that very
first reveal trailer I do feel like I
need to point out this spell here which
is most likely glacias there's a
possibility maybe impedimenta as well I
still think glacias is the most likely
candidate however I will caution folks
to say that it is very possible things
could have changed clearly this spell
was at one point in the game maybe it's
still in the game and it's one of these
unknown slots that we don't know about
yet but seeing that there have already
been a few changes we've noticed from
that initial trailer also important to
keep in mind that anything could change
and if you want to see the absolute best
look we've gotten yet at uninterrupted
combat the second gameplay showcase
where they walk through that dark arts
battle arena is by far the best place to
see it in that very same showcase they
also gave an incredible breakdown of the
open world and I have a video breaking
all of that down already here on YouTube
I'll link it here on the right side of
your screen so check that one out next
if you guys are looking for more
Hogwarts Legacy content from now leading
all the way up to launch and of course
after launch as well make sure to hit
that subscribe button before you go as
always thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon